welcome back to gamma unfiltered hosted
by me josh smith and today we are joined
by the new queen
of pirajamas it's bridgeton's phoebe
develop
woo
[Music]
hello darling hi babe how are you
i'm good how are you i'm good babes well
we are gonna get
into it those courses are coming off and
the chat is about to flow
like lady whistle downs papers isn't it
it's about to go down
let it be known if there's a scandal
i shall uncover it
and share every last detail
it completely turns this period drama
theme
on its head like it totally destroys it
rebuilds it and makes it completely
fresh
for you when you first got approached
about it
and when you were filming it what made
it feel so modern what made it feel so
contemporary and what really made you
feel like
it actually reflected the world you
actually live in in a way as well
if we're not seeing ourselves reflected
in in art then we're not going to engage
with it and i think it's so
it's so true and it's what's so
brilliant about bridgeton for me
just the that feminism doesn't come in
one
you know in one it doesn't
come in one form it comes in different
forms and daphne isn't
isn't your obvious feminist but
she's still in charge of her own
destiny what are the biggest differences
you're seeing in
those kind of scripts that you were
getting say like five years ago you're
getting now like
how what are the nuances in that kind of
sexist
um dialogue that's changed well i think
i mean
using it with with bridgeton for example
and what was
so brilliant about the script is that it
is so much
the female gaze within the story
like there's there's shots and i've seen
it a million times
you know watching bond films and and
watching
these sort of male-driven films where
the man
is laid back in bed with his hands
behind his head and the woman is
you know you see the silhouette of her
back and she's naked and he's just
watching her and and she's the woman is
the sexualized
object and in bridgeton we flip that and
it was so
it's so interesting to watch because it
is very much
daphne's perspective of simon and her
seeing him
and and aspects of his body and
um and herb feeling that
sexual sexual drive towards him
which i it's so funny because until you
see that
or until you experience doing it that
way you don't really realize that
actually
it has been the other way for so so long
um so finally i think that's
that's shifting and we're reading
scripts uh turning it on its head
and i mean like one of the episodes is
very
focused on that aspect of the story and
i mean how difficult do you find it to
do those kind of sex scenes where you
have to be like right
here we go we're doing it like how
difficult do you find
those scenes and how do you build
yourself up to doing them because i kind
of feel like it must be
sort of liberating in some ways and also
just almost like so in your head at the
same time as well
yeah i think weirdly the hardest scenes
that i had to do were the ones on my own
that were
quite sexually driven because there's no
one to sort of
vibe off those scenes were so essential
to daphne's journey
you know as a woman and finding her
sexuality and
and sex for the sake of sex is is fine
um but when it really feeds the
story which it did for daphne and it
does it is very much her
her coming of age and her sexual
awakening then it
it all felt like it really needed to be
there i've done sex scenes in the past
and
it's all just like action go just
do it whatever you want to do just just
do it and
and you feel very out of control when
that's happening but
with a coordinator on set we we blocked
everything we rehearsed everything like
a fight scene
so i knew exactly where reggae was going
to put his hand
um at what point and actually it really
frees you up
because there isn't that weird thing of
oh what's
what's he going to do now and also just
me as a woman coming into my own and
being able to say
you know actually that i don't feel too
comfortable with that and
we get we've been given more power to be
able to say no
as well and i think for a long time that
wasn't a thing
women didn't weren't allowed to speak up
because i think your character in
bridgeton
isn't really seeking approval from
anyone apart from herself and that's the
kind of journey she does go on along the
way
what do you mean she's taught you
about yourself and what have you learned
from her
but i mean there was a moment there's a
scene in in bridgeton where
and it was quite funny because it it was
my
least favorite scene to film and the one
of the most difficult
scenes for me and it was when daphne
walks down the stairs to greet the
prince and everyone
in the ball turns and they look they
look at her and they look at
you know all the background were
watching me
walk down these stairs and it was
actually the most
uncomfortable scene ever i just
absolutely hated filming it because it
just i just didn't
i didn't feel like that um
i didn't feel very confident that day i
think i woke up and i just wasn't
feeling like
in my power in my strength that day so
that scene to shoot was
so uncomfortable and watching it
and being like oh okay you look the
exact opposite
of what you're feeling is so interesting
and i think that happens in life a lot
where what we're portraying on the
outside
is is usually very different to what's
going on
on the inside i was super nervous about
leading you know a netflix show and and
chandelin
being involved and that was i just it
was nerve-wracking
it was a big a big deal and
and daphne's story is the first one but
as soon as i met
all of the cast i mean i know people say
this on interviews all the time but
we genuinely are like so close all of us
and
we all got on so well and um
especially you know the bridgeton family
we were literally like a family on set
which was amazing how amazing was that
wardrobe
experience like you was it just like
everything or more so i was living in
l.a when i got
the uh call that i had the job and i
think the first thing i did when i
touched down
in england was have a wardrobe a fitting
and i walk into this like full warehouse
of costumes and everyone there's like so
many
incredible designers and and it's
basically a factory
just for bridgeton making all these
costumes and i was like oh my god and
it's when
it's it hit me i mean i had over 100
dresses i think so it was
it was pretty mad how did you cope with
having
the constraining garments underneath as
well because does that
how's that ultra the way you perceive
yourself i was wearing a
half corset thank god um so not the full
full-blown thing um and it's weird
yeah it's weird because your boobs look
very different they look very different
because they're pushed up to your ears
so you're like okay yeah the push-up
push-up bra but
even worse than that and i don't really
wear bras
so it was interesting to see my boobs in
that condition
you'd take it off and you'd have marks
and they were uncomfortable and tight
and
you'd think thank god we've come a long
way from wearing these because
yeah and and they had actually it might
have just been but
they would they would work they would
have nighttime ones as well i mean it's
quite
it's crazy what women had to go through
you've been on this sort of self-esteem
journey like everyone has in their lives
but if you go back to a time in your
life where you could be a friend to
yourself
and give yourself a piece of advice what
would it be
and what would you say it would probably
be about three years ago and i would say
everything that is meant to be will be
and it's not meant for you honey
and trust me in three years you will
thank
the lord that that happened it was tough
at times and
i was finding myself and i went through
points
of really really low self-esteem
particularly in my early 20s
of just like why is this not working
what do i need to do who do i need to be
for this
for this to happen and i think that's
really dangerous when you start going
down that
road and trying to change yourself the
last two years really for me have
been when i've grown up a lot and and
found myself and sort of known okay
this is this is who i am and i'm gonna
push for that and that's when things
started happening when i
when i got confidence in myself when i
was like okay this is it i'm gonna
this is who i am and that's when it
seemed to click
like everything just clicked into place
a little bit and i still have days where
i wake up and i'm like i'm
i don't want to be me today because i am
quite self-aware anyway but in the sense
of like
what your brain is telling you you know
like i think when you're younger you
listen to what your brain is telling you
if your brain tells you
you know your your hair's not very nice
that day you're going to believe it
yeah but as you get older you start to
realize actually
i do you know that isn't i don't have to
listen to that
and i can acknowledge it and go oh okay
that's me feeling insecure today because
i'm a bit tired
or whatever and i'm not going to listen
to it and it's always important to
remember that a negative
can ultimately turn into such an
empowering positive right
has there been say like a no or
something that's happened like a
negative thing that's
actually turned out to be a positive
thing in retrospect you know this
industry is so
full of rejection like for
the last 10 years of my life i've been
going up for every single part
under the sun and and it's i'm so
grateful to have got bridgeton but and
it's so interesting when you watch
people's success because you do only see
the success aspect you don't see all of
the
all of the no's and the letdowns and
there are so many
particularly in this industry but
it shapes you the rejection and
makes you stronger and tougher and
and i really appreciate all the notes
that i've had in my life and all the
rejection that i've had in my life
because
i wouldn't be sat here today so i think
self
self self worth is such
a valuable thing to have and sometimes
it i just think it's really important
for us to have it regardless of
of the noise around us because
you know if we're constantly waiting for
someone to say you're worthy
for us to feel worthy then
you know it's not that doesn't lead to a
very
happy life all around so i think
you've got to feel the self-worth first
and then the rest
will will come